this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation it
is time for the midseason finale of
invincible Aaron I love filming with you
post working out get a be in shorts and
be smelly cuz it makes me feel
Invincible how are you the real Aaron
Alexander oh I'm doing so well the real
Greg Alba it's the Greg Al are you real
are you authentic no you're fake very
fake everything I say I like here it is
just a play Kate to all of you and I've
been doing it for a how long 10 years
I've been lying for 10 years lying for
10 whole years strange comedy today
anyway guys leave a like on this video
be sure to uh check us out on patreon so
you can catch the full in through action
watch song where you sync up with your
own copy of invincible thank you to all
who have joined we also cover several
things over there exclusively with
highlights and watch Longs included
let's do
it
paranoid about that YouTube intro yeah
do you think like people will think I'm
being serious no thank God yes oh [__]
really yeah they're going to they're
going to stop watching a [__] you're
going to lose all 1 million subscribers
he's not authentic it's not real I mean
by now they should know a damn it it's
been a
while it's been a while you'll better
start with that okay find out what he's
been up
to
that senseless
oh oh we're going to see exactly where
he flew to yeah it looks like
it so
exciting o I just got nipple
[Laughter]
chills I stepped in
an man the melancholic tone of this
season seriously now we see the effects
of what omim man's actions had on him as
sleep beneath the gold oh wa W he flew
for a long time oh man learn to
[Music]
serve damn has he really
changed holy [__] cuz he failed his
mission he can't go back to the vites
yeah it's just a lost soul
[Music]
now a literal space wander this is
beautiful damn right space Nomad this is
like the Barbie and Ken
Montage exactly exactly the same the
center the center of the world center of
the world and he's just right there in
the very center of this
[Music]
planet oh and a black
hole okay okay this makes sense how they
came to to come together he saved them
him being on a different side of the
Galaxy I wonder how much time has passed
for him versus how much P time has
passed on
Earth what makes five to seven business
days that's how long it takes for a
character Arc to come to
[Music]
completion looks tired I will conquer
you I don't know who you are but we owe
you our lives won't you stay tell us
your name where you come from
well I like the beard yeah it looks good
with
[Music]
it hello son love how he shaved it back
into a
mustache hug
him I think they're going to hug I
predict a
hug yeah like he's going to
[Music]
Flinch I missed you that's truly
conflicting feelings yeah thin told me
that they needed my help It's
Complicated come with me and no why
would you lie to me again you killed
thousands of people why would you think
I'd ever want to see you again well you
did hu him I can't believe you put them
up to this made them lie to me too just
listen I don't have to listen to
anything you say I made a
mistake that's a little one a mistake
yeah son no you don't get to call me
that anymore oo you could have started
with I'm sorry is is going to say it I'm
not sorry I regret nothing you whoa to
your father I'll get you a ship home but
there's something you need to see first
no noot wasn't lying to you I don't
care I'm on
edge 5 minutes for them not you play
Mark the Montage of you traveling show
him the beard the beard will change his
mind they asked me to be their Emperor
Emperor conqueror what's the difference
I mean this is more of a benevolent type
of
ruling oh my God my husband's told me so
much about
Anda what the is going on wait who's the
voice actress of her I'm surprised
you're married to Mom I can't go back to
Earth Mark the life I had there is over
no but you're the real star of the show
super glad you got to show me how great
your life is without us that's not what
I wanted to show you you could have
given a heads up about the whole tongue
and the bug thing pretty uncool brother
how's that math this is your little
brother you got to
be you got to be Invincible
kidding strange title smash on that
right oh poor Debbie little does she
know Nolan is with a bug person and has
moved on it's a a purple baby thank God
that bug turned out more human than bug
what's the color breeding on
that wow this is just a depressing
composed Montage
episode I hope somebody edits The omn
Man flying with her walking it's
interesting to do a
[Music]
mirroring why me you could have taken
Earth whenever you wanted why did you
marry me her feet must be hurting so bad
have so many steps on that Fitbit you
weren't real Mark and you almost took
him too I never knew you at all I never
even knew You Man The Voice work on her
is great this season I really feel like
I'm watching a full-fledged performance
yeah know she's putting her all into
[Music]
it the world of the
living not this time I remember the
machine machine the explosion of course
you do you have all of my memories my
experiences because I'm the Clone yep
there you go we know exactly who's the
original and who's the
inferior he turned into too face Debbie
it's it's Donald you're not the real
Donald my Donald died he was my favorite
character last
season oh great now he's going to have
all the extra ST dread too oh I wonder
if they Ed the cloning technology from
uh the molder twins oh that would make
[Music]
sense this is old
glasses yeah but why him what's so
special about
[Music]
him all in all those glasses managed to
survive that Rubble pretty
indestructible a new wife a kid you just
replaced us except you know bugs
I didn't replace you Mark or your mother
I was lost when I left Earth I found
these people I saved lives it was like I
had a purpose again I liked being a hero
we're only allowed to procreate with
genetically similar species humans for
example look at you you are a viltrumite
in almost every way oh my God he's going
to have to protect him by now VTR knows
I've left my post and they'll find this
planet and and when they do they'll see
your brother as inferior and kill him
well why don't you leave the planet omn
man I can't stop them alone but we can
stop them whoa what a turn of events
your brother and all these people will
die without our help you're the reason
they're in danger you signed their death
warrant not me and now I'm asking you to
help me save them you did kind of do go
there knowing that this is a possibility
omn man how can I help I couldn't even
beat you we can start training right
away oh my
God a different meting this is so crazy
I love
[Laughter]
it the anxiety of the situation what was
that oh it could be the three that went
after Allen oh looks like y sure enough
three already no time to train they're
here it's too late filite soldiers Mark
get Anda and your brother to safety
where Andressa will show you go there's
no time I don't know if I would
acknowledge that kid as my brother you
don't know him but like what Technic
technically is your brother squash
him like all the bugy
is should have packed your bags better
robot we seen this dude in a while yeah
he's in the first episode put robot's
thing back and I won't beat the living
[__] out of you how's that for a deal
you want this
back come and get it you know she could
whoop your ass without even trying THX
and lifespans aren't like humans only
one of your years seriously it's never
seem short to me damn I didn't knowingly
try to replace your mother your father
saved my life at first it was hard to
know him he was so hurt so closed off
after what happened on Earth so
hot so it's true great Nolan fathered a
child with an earthwoman Steve
Harvey If you fight well we may allow
you to join the Empire if not you'll
die maybe I
wasn't stay away from my children
lcan hey I got full oh my God dud save
him save him
[Music]
protect you've disarmed your people [__]
he's evenly
matched you deserve
death
who he just do that oh my God oh my God
yeah that's crazy Humanity really
changed him after slaughtering everyone
and having a kid
yeah genocide will do that to you
genocide you
Calla shooting shooting I guess when
your arm's a gun you really only have
one trick it's a good
trick not tonight it is it I'm curious
why this is one of the plot lines yeah
right I feel like she hasn't got as much
to do this season I mean we are seeing
her emotions come out she is taking out
a lot of anger on his person true when
she could end it very quickly if she
wanted to we're not done yet
not by a long
shot oh no that your powers cause
problems when collateral
damage oh no
no yes ouch
ouch
whoa
I mean they they got to be dead can she
resurrect people I wouldn't be surprised
if she can if she can create life she
can Restore Life are they okay please
please just help them got to be more
responsible with your powers would you
say the same thing if that was a
man absolutely not cuz I'm a raging
sexist Debbie are you home oh is that
art can I come come in it is you okay
I'm fine I just I'm not fine fine
usually means you're not I always
thought you were the strong one to
handle your life the way you did a
that's sweet no one has superpowers he's
indestructible that's not strength yeah
the real reason we're all still alive
and not slaves that is true Nolan was
always off fighting something and you
made things work without him now it's
just official you don't need the bum you
never did oh wow art I am glad you
showed up this season for that one
scene cuz that is some really making a
difference run
now this is
horrifying oh
no you guys did a bang up job
[Music]
Dad Dad
uh-oh
uh-oh what why do I care about them they
were weak short-lived barely a species
oh no I'm not supposed to feel this way
oh no he's crying this is how you should
have felt on
Earth doesn't know what to do with all
these emotions
use those emotions Nolan I'll kill you
for what you did to these people then do
it that was going to be
awesome I really hope Nolan doesn't die
can you imagine I don't think they're
going to kill him here because you're
Nolan's son I'll make this quick
oh did the Judo
Chop Chop his arm off she has a blade on
the end of her on the end of her hair
that's crazy there I promised I'd make
it quick oh
[__] Mark what are you doing she's
tearing you
apart she's trying to kill you Mark if
you're not trying to kill her you're
going to die don't think act you need to
fight like a Vite God oh my
God we're all dead
you me your brother and every single
thren on this planet they'll probably go
to earth right
after to be a hero he has to embrace his
ultimate vulture you don't need to fight
like a hero fight like a a
warrior grab it play against
yes break those limbs come
on yes
yes oh man so good his strength has
always come in wanting to fight for
something more meaningful more than
himself use that rage
too
finally oo oh oh oh what a bone
crunching like look at that call book wa
great editing my God yeah great editing
oh oh oh oh damn
throwback do that win
[Music]
it om man's going to do it for him he's
going have in
him I know he's not dead but like you
held back you held back do you
regret scre you
dead going to rip her scalp off rip it
oh
oh my
God that's a
[Laughter]
[Music]
cross mark you did it are you
okay
[Music]
no don't
worry it's over is your guard down why
is your
guard why is your guard down next time
you kill somebody
make sure they're dead holding his
guts no it can't be he didn't kill him
could be paralyzed though I don't want
Nolan's book money the survivors in
Chicago need it more than I do and if
you can't find a way to get it to them I
will Savage Planet Savage beasts if you
change your mind I
won't C's not a bad guy I don't always
treats him like he's the
enemy oh my God oh my God are they
getting they both getting taken possibly
he might be taking him to Vite no way is
he going to have to rescue his pops dad
Mark don't forget the good I did wow my
[Music]
books read my books Mark read my books
I'm going to take Invincible with them
is there a clue in there
possibly
oh now she's getting rid of them seems
like it where can you get a
[Laughter]
copy the man with an invincible
[Music]
gun or dude oh no she gets depressing
[Laughter]
[Music]
Montage why do you keep trying to have a
relationship with him they're just the
worst cuz the that guilt's inherit to
her her dad's voice is ingrained her
like cuz she thinks that she is
bad are you a
cyborg he was bleeding he was
not what is it bent oh it is what does
the bent mean I think it means he's part
robot my name is General C you've
survived your first true battle and
proven yourself worthy of your
viltrumite heritage
oh [__] it oh your father will be
executed and you will return to Earth
you will assume his mission and prepare
the planet for our rule oh my God is
that the voice of Darth blood you can
kill a few humans to convince them to
capitulate or we will kill Millions if
we arrive to find you or your planet
still defiant against us that is the
beginning of The Season's coming full
circle yeah and unlike your father
we do not change our minds oh my God
he's being forced to become a vulture M
oh this is this is insane this is a
crazy episode man this is really crazy
how he going to get back home too he's
got a bunch of ships to choose from he
still doesn't know the way yeah we got
to go back to the merer twins we got to
see our uh the black dude too the
multi-dimensional guy with his big ass
brain messy
wiring sloppy welding
obviously the work of a
clone why stop at one idiot clone when I
can have so many more oh yeah it's
true I hope one of you is better in the
kitchen that's why he wanted to
establish this himself as
original I poisoned
him when it's not laced with a modified
MotoX that is I just love how they just
are always willing to kill off each
other sometimes things are the way they
are for a good
reason there's way more F bombs this
episode than ever oh
totally feel like neither of them were
ever the original cuz they die so much
they never know oh yeah yeah none of
them are
no original that was a gnarly gnarly
episode that was really good a lot of I
think it's the most action we've seen
though all season
two probably trying to see if we see the
other cast members names see here oh
most
brutal they to wait a
whole five four months before the next
one or a few months yeah damn let's see
hold on hold on yeah okay yeah Clancy
Brown Clancy Brown played um dark blood
and and he's also playing Craig General
Craig Clancy Brown get that work he's
one of the best voice
actors yeah wait a minute though wait a
minute though I
think I think it's important
that when having to navigate around you
don't want your communication to get
interfered via
satellite you know yeah and that's why I
have a very important message I got to
convey to the audience think thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
want to work with us it's an instant yes
you've likely heard about expressvpn for
online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a
very real incident recently with
Spectrum shutting down my internet and
contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I
realized I hadn't actually activated my
expressvpn on my new laptop that I got a
couple of months ago so I was paying the
consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years
ago that made expressvpn my go-to for
both security and freedom I mean it and
yes what you've heard is true believe me
this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on
Netflix that are not available in your
country this means accessing a vast rate
of content of over a 100 countries like
a global Cinema your fingertips it's
super easy open expressvpn switch
locations refresh the browser and there
you have it whether it's kramas on South
Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube
or more expressvpn has you covered and
it's incredibly fast ensuring no
buffering or lack for smooth HD
streaming it's versatile too working on
not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows on
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com reex and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you again all right guys well yes
thank you for sponsoring this video and
um man Aaron please
what what did you think about
out this episode obviously the big
talking point is going to
be the Muller twins of course the
biggest part of this episode the most
controversial part the most exciting
part no um this episode was great this
episode was really good uh we got a lot
of stuff with omn man which was
unexpected to see the complexity of
where he's been since we started this
the season yeah man I was I was really
enthralled by everything happening on
that front and because especially with
you know him finding this species that
is made of bugs and the the dichotomy I
guess or the difference in the fact that
he viewed his wife as a pet someone that
was uh of human descent was something
that he could uh mix with have
intercourse with sexual relations but
these bug people have a shorter span of
life so the fact that he's able to find
humanity trying to sound
smart I'm formulating my thoughts damn
it we're getting from here to
here so anyway
he so he yeah he's able to find humanity
in something that was that had such a
short lifespan which I feel like really
shows the fact that he's grown because
you know you you see fly like normal
house flies and we know that they have
such a short short lifespan in them
themselves so the fact that he's able to
do that kind of is like a representation
of how much he's grown because yeah plus
he has a son uh yeah there's a lot of
really good stuff in here from Donald
realizing that he's not entirely human
to Al Adam Eve kind of realizing that or
I guess backtracking because she is
listening to the voice of her parents at
least that's the implication of it it
because she has doubts about herself and
her abilities because her dad implanted
that thing that she's dangerous and her
power she can't be trusted which is kind
of a sad like her mental Kryptonite to
the fact that you know she's essentially
God but she has all these internalized
beliefs from her her abusive parents
that she can't fully come into her own
as a powerful uh
being now we got some stuff with what I
guess we had a little bit of the stuff
with the
Mark's friends but that wasn't really
much of the story but yeah I I like the
episode a lot uh I think we have a
really big cast this season so we have
to like really spread out everything
like Adam Eve wasn't even in the last
episode none of the people from the the
main team were part of this episode
either so I don't know this we got half
of a season worth
of
stuff yeah it's a great mid-season
finale though great midseason finale fin
Al it's a great Mak you want to come
back and see what unfolds yeah
definitely the stakes are high stakes
are high high stakes high stakes value
high stakes high stakes rare Stakes uh
but yeah I liked it a lot I think one of
the hardest parts about writing is truly
knowing how to embrace the gray of a
situation it's really easy to
acknowledge the gray but more often than
not I think um a writer often makes a
choice of not sitting there and
ultimately choosing a path between
somewhere that lean a little more black
and white I think that's one of the
hardest parts when you're working with
screen time versus real life um that's
where the har partk can come in that's
one thing I'm really respecting about
this season in particular is they truly
let you sit with the gray you know even
right from EV every every debate and
argument that was acknowledged I
think they would really explore the
arena
and the vast array
of the thoughts and emotions that would
you know rise to the surface on such a
unique unique problem like with Mark of
he hugs his dad and it's like no go
after yourself and why do you want me no
this it's like that that pingpong battle
in between and then even seeing like the
kid and like why should I care but but
it's it's not her fault you know like
the constant back and forth even with
Adam Eve I think like uh I think it
might be a little bit more layered in
the sense of there's so much wrong about
the way her parents treat her she knows
that there's so many psychologically
abusive sides especially on the side of
her dad yeah however there might be a
layer there where you might be a little
bit right about hey you are not God you
are not someone who has all the answers
and maybe if you don't keep acting like
you know everything you might create a
better sense of awareness on when you're
handling certain situations because she
has made mistakes from thinking she
knows best you know and that's that's
part of what I mean by that gray of it
is there can be the acknowledgement like
he is a messed up guy he is he does
treat her bad there's also this one
quality though that he might be right
about you know like like there can be
these multiple layers like one of my
favorite moments is like Mark saying
Mark just telling the bug mom um
I I know none of this is not is your
fault none of this is your fault but it
still hurts and that's what I I think
that is probably the perfect
encapsulation of what I mean by the gray
you know
and I just love that about what they're
doing here uh from Debbie that Debbie is
a great example of that too of the The
Crib like I hate you so much you did all
this wrong why do I miss you though you
know why what like you can have both you
can have these coexisting feelings and
the show lets those those colors coexist
together versus just choosing one side
eventually a character has to choose a
path that's what we do in life we we
feel out everything but we have to make
a choice regardless and we have to move
on ahead uh whether that be something
that's bad for us or good for us we make
a choice and that's what they're doing
with their characters like they they
just let them see all this this and I
like there I think there's it's really
hard to find a show that does that or a
movie like it's way harder with a movie
a movies such a shorter runtime you have
to tell something a lot more you know in
a more specific time frame and but for a
show like this is this is true this true
character exploration this true
character driven narrative while giving
you like awesome visuals and great fight
scenes and you know like superhero
complexities and stuff but this is so
much more human than a lot of shows that
are about just human beings you know
and I I think this is a this is probably
my
favorite just because of that front and
willingness uh it it is probably my
favorite superhero show I think we've
seen all year yeah I'd have to agree
with that yeah no yeah kind of to build
off what you were saying about the the
gray the fact that D with Nolan too with
Nolan too yeah cuz he's cuz he like
choked his son like
crying yeah cuz he he feels like why do
I feel things and yeah it's no man it's
just it's it's really interesting
because we you know we we're in this age
of of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
right and so
sexist Jesus no in the no we're we're
the we're the age of Marvel right and I
feel like there is such an apprehension
towards having people that are in
emotional gr areas because they want to
make things as likable as possible but I
think by not trying to make something
that that's widely appealing and showing
something that's gray showing something
that's more human and more complicated I
think that endear us to the characters
we're watching more because we see
elements of ourselves within that
because humans are complicated you know
humans do have multifaceted sometimes
conflicting desires and I think it's
important that we're having that
represented in the show and I like the
fact that this is something that is not
only complex but it's also authentically
comic Booky as well because we're seeing
weird alien stuff we're seeing clones
we're seeing demons you know but it's
very much rooted in that human conflict
and all the performances really show up
to play as well you know we don't it
doesn't come off as like this heightened
version of what what acting is you know
it feels very much in spite of the fact
that it's animated like these performers
are giving their all showing that Nuance
within those performances which I think
is is great and yeah I I firmly agree
that this is one of the the best shows
not only comic book shows best shows
that have been on this year yeah and I I
think they take advantage of the fact
that it's an animated medium and in in
all the right ways I think uh I I really
love this this series a lot and I think
I think the the way they've Amplified
this season with that's it's so strange
they got a lot going on but I'm like I I
feel like they're not in a rush to wrap
it all even when it comes back to finish
off season 2
they're not in a rush to like end it
down season two you know like I'm like
yeah let's stick around for the Long
Haul because this exploration is is
great because this is is more than just
World building which they do you know
they they've opened the Multiverse and
stuff and and and I love how they're not
bogged down by excitement like it is so
melancholic it's so sad like it's sad
but it's also going to be funny the
great I think they're really they it
surprises me that
uh of how this show continues to
surprise me uh in that regard because
this season especially has doubled down
on
existentialism
Consciousness uh all these different
things that you cannot really spew about
while you're in the middle of a reaction
so you make some stupid joke one more
often the dumb thoughts that pop into
our
heads we not try to be dumb we were just
dumb in the moment and then we think
about it after you know what process you
know our our complex thoughts but I mean
to get some of the main things out of
the way like uh om yeah omn man has has
been a a nice surprise like I I
believe again like they didn't just try
slingshotting him until like he's a hero
now you know like I love when he choked
Mark and he's and it's just he's
watching the devastation and any other
show would just have you tease with the
rage but the last thing you're going to
do is have him choke his own kid like
the the fight of of
feeling hurt yeah you know the pain of
the loss of love that like the
compassion weighing against your heart
and and your fighting literally the pH
most physical representation of fighting
against it by your own flesh and blood
uh was was a powerful moment I was like
damn this is heartbreaking and uh even
is pleading at the end and to get these
other vites were wow we' got like we
thought omn man was bad right what the
hell we have on our hands now you know a
whole planet of people that are survival
of the fittest and like we are the top
race and also the fact at the end that
you know Mark has been wrestling all
season long with am I like my dad like
no I need to prove I'm not like my dad
in this this overwhelming guilt that he
needs to be the best hero that he can be
but that need to be hero was originally
inspired by the fact that he looked up
to his dad like to such a great degree
and now he's threatened by his dadge
Heritage to be the thing that he fears
most to be the thing that he's most
insecure about and yeah I'm really
wondering how that's going to come into
play because yeah if he doesn't they're
going to come they're going to ks to
fill his dad's role so maybe he's gonna
find a way
to beat the vill MS I don't know I don't
know may that because that scene with
Allen hasn't happened yet as far as this
show has shown us I mean I hope Alan
heels cuz from the last episode it looks
like he's going to die cuz uh Optimus
Prime is the mole so who knows I don't
know that a whole plot too that whole
plot there's a lot of plots a lot of
plots happening but yeah it's like a big
expansive universe but damn they keep it
like whenever you cut to something
you're not thinking about what's going
on over here right like you're just that
moment you're just in the moment of
what's Happening you know yeah and it's
not about like theories and all this
other [__] like you're just watching
like like even like I didn't really I
like Donald last season but I wasn't
care about I wasn't like oh like oh guy
have a bummer he died because he was
like a likable
personality right but what they're doing
here which is just all mainly tone based
it's like yeah this is compelling what
you're watching this guy go through like
what is he who is this Donald is this is
the same doled ises he a resurrected is
he a robot and what does this say about
again like the existential themes this
see like they like the last episode
dealt a lot with characters who
experience death over and over again you
know yeah and and and so I really I
really love what they're doing there and
what they're doing with omn man I think
is really compelling stuff you can't
kill them off even if he gets killed off
the comics you can't kill him off he's
the thing that brings in the
dollars he's the bread winner here how
happy to have him back yeah to see where
his his mental state is at now and what
how is Mark GNA save him is he going to
save him like what's going to happen
there I I know like who would who would
ban with him right who would risk their
neck to save yeah who believe who'
believe Mark that he's changed if he's
the person leading that charge to save
him like the and to call the show
Invincible he has to go through like the
most insane insurmountable obstacles in
the most isolating types of scenarios in
order to gain that P that that image of
invincibility you know in order to
really gained that uh that title H in
the most apt way so I I I'm so
fascinated by what direction we're going
and so I think for a mid-season finale
it does feel like there's so much that's
been set up and so much has been done
that even though yeah I do feel like we
didn't watch Eight Episodes I still feel
like I got like a full meal yeah solid
experience filling experience normally
sometimes these midseason final like H
seems like we were just kind of like
what's happening oh okay now we got to
go Cliffhanger I'm like no but they
still told like a solid package oh yeah
in this part one yeah uh I loved it I
really loved it a lot and and yeah what
they did with Debbie's growth is great
and then like even art like again it's
about quality and versus quantity art
shows up for one scene be like yo I got
some troops to drop to you I'm like
goddamn right yeah but every there'd be
more dead people if it wasn't for Debbie
and stilling some good at him yeah yeah
cuz she yeah she was she's the heart you
know she she held him at Bay until markk
was able to find the strength within and
showing like no I do have actual
strength yeah and it's true she does uh
I just took the oldest whitest guy
and this little soul patch over here um
phenomenal stuff phenomenal stuff all
around great Voice work and uh good
violence again missed the violence yeah
first two episodes were good but I think
these last two episodes are
great yeah yeah the first the first two
were good and I really appreciate what
they were doing um but you know you have
to kind of sit it through like you can't
you can't have the last two without the
first two yeah you a natural buildup
aggressive show should yeah yeah oh wow
guys what did you think about these two
man I thought I I thought it was these
were excellent and again this just
solidifies is this depending on whenever
this show ends which I imagine wouldn't
be for a while this could go down as
like the best superhero show oh yeah
totally I know some people can't just
give it to that only because it's
animated and not liveaction but [__] the
writing is so much better superb than so
many superhero shows yeah I mean the the
boys is great too but I think that this
really there's a sense of cynicism to
the boys that's kind of like making fun
of comic book tropes in like in media
but I think this is very sincere in its
love of comic books while also having a
self-awareness that it's a comic book
exactly yeah yeah couldn't said it
better myself yeah well we complet
completed each other's
sandwiches I honestly don't remember
what the rest of that sentence
[Music]
was we did
it you have a cough going on
nope nope I'm healthy you got the you
got Theona nope you sure want we do a
test on camera play it out in real time
let's do it you how terrible of a human
being you would look you want to stick
on my nose make out after yep full
tongue just like omn man the
[__] like this how we run the rejects
around here would would you dip me or
would I dip you for like our our on
screen kiss is that how that work you
you want to like I dip you you of course
th% dip you I have longer hair so you
know just
like like that just look at our physical
statures it makes more sense that I dip
you exactly you look like manlier cuz
I'm like I'm larger than so he just like
oh yeah so it makes sense that I be the
one to dip you
exactly breaking stereotypes here
yeah
anyway after a very serious
conversation and the classic style Aaron
happy to be covering this with you my
friend was this the first show we
covered or was it umbrella AC I think
was Umbrella Academy the first Umbrella
Academy was the first one we did yeah
and then we did this one after yeah is
this one after yeah cuz I think we did
Umbrella Academy 2020 this is
2021 yep yeah that's how times we've
changed' changed times have
changed it's
[Music]
growth